Japan is a world power whose decisions
have a profound influence around the
world but it's also a society bound by
tradition and with that change can come
very slowly that includes opportunities
for women in politics and in government
lately there's been a shake-up of the
old order Adriana Diaz has the story
from Tokyo my way of thinking is quite
different from the previous governor's
at least I'm not sure by mystic as
Tokyo's first female governor
Yuriko Koike is used to breaking glass
ceilings Japanese politics have long
been dominated by men and some are
hostile to change a former governor said
we can't leave Tokyo to a woman who
wears too much makeup what did you think
when you heard that oh I know
minorities Eva unfortunately in Japan
men still looked down on women she said
I want to change that but I should thank
the governor his comment gave me more
female votes since taking office in
August she's battled government
corruption and financial waste including
cost overruns from Tokyo's 2020 Olympics
that drive made her popular with voters
an unpopular amongst her City Hall
colleagues resistant to change but her
biggest challenge she says is getting
more women into positions of power
demodex yeah if we can show that female
leadership in politics and society can
make a difference she told us I think
that will encourage more women to get
into politics Japan ranks 160 forth out
of 193 countries in terms of women in
Parliament last among the group of seven
industrialized nations women make up
less than 10% of japan's lower house
compared to 19% in the US House of
Representatives but there are signs of a
shift in the last year three women rose
to positions that traditionally pave the
way to the Prime Minister's Office
including Koike defense minister tamami
inada and the leader of Japan's main
opposition party renho Murata why is the
gender gap so wide here simple Salone
lands in Japan has long operated on the
ID
that men work outside the home and women
belong in the home she told us we need a
society that offers choices a former
model and TV news anchor renho doesn't
mind standing out in a sea of suited men
his estate there are a few women who
aspire to political leadership here she
said all I can do is try to change the
system for the next generation
they'll good that change will likely
come slowly the Japanese government will
fall far short of its goal to fill 30%
of management roles with women by 2020
still for pioneers like Koike hon it's a
start it's you know it's like the
Japanese baseball player Ichiro Suzuki
who batted 3000 hits
she told us instead of homeruns I want
to eventually rack up 3000 hits and
succeed through steady patient efforts
for CBS this morning Saturday Adriana
Diaz Tokyo the US it should be noted
ranks 104 out of 190 in terms of you a
female representation and yeah we're not
doing much better now we got some work
to do yeah we do all right